good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday i hope
everyone's having an amazing bright and
positive
filled day here yes it already is
because the week is just flying by and
this is just one of the best weeks it's
one of the best weeks i just can't
stress enough how weeks like this
really put into perspective how integral
a four-day work week is it's just such a
brilliant concept
and i think that as a country we just
need to start thinking about it more
start talking about it more
and then maybe start putting it into
action even more for sure but we've had
this conversation before and we decided
that a four-day work week starts with us
and yeah that's true we need to be the
change that we should see
no you're so right and so i think that
the onus is on
us to make that change yeah no i i hear
you
and i definitely agree like i just think
we get so few of these it's like you
know mlk day
presidents weekend uh whatever there's
only so many and
i can't even name the mom um are you
gonna sit here
like monday and like honestly
they're so infrequent but then when they
come up they're like this little gems
yeah and you just really realize like
how much better of a balanced
life the four to three day ratio is so
true
it's sick it's sick but i'm upset not
enough people are talking about it i
know but that's why we have to talk
about it like
okay maybe like we do a weekly segment
here um
like just you know an update on the
progress the campaigning for the
four-day workweek yeah i'm just saying
like if you really want to talk about a
four day work week like
the toast needs to be four days a week
otherwise what are you doing yeah i know
but it's hard to be the first person to
it's hard to be the first person to do
anything
yeah but that's what's being a leader
and not a follower no you're right you
know it's hard
it's very challenging so that's just
something to think about um we have a
great show for you guys today obviously
a bunch of stories
real housewives of salt lake city and
part one of the oc reunion were on last
night
both pretty good so we will head into
that in the tv recap segment
but before that we just got we got lots
to talk about we do have lots to talk
about some personal updates
yesterday um your haircut
oh my god my hair cut i put bruno before
myself
your true mother bruno lost a tooth
yesterday and it was just
so cute i left it under his pillow are
you gonna keep it
you put in like a little box i want to
get like a little box or something
because usually
puppies lose their teeth but they
swallow them i've never seen one
sometimes it comes down their food and
then they swallow it
they just swallow it on their own or
they like lose it on the street so he
was having a bully stick on bed
last night and i just saw the tooth
there and it was just so precious so we
left it under his pillow the tooth fairy
came she brought him
so much kibble and toys that's so cute
and he's
he's living the life that is such and by
the way you also like more importantly
got a haircut
more importantly i got a haircut nothing
too crazy but i'm sure if you're
watching on the youtube you can really
tell the difference let me move my
microphone
so just a lot of layers took off all the
dead ends
just happy and healthy hair there's
really nothing better than like a
perfect trim
of course fun haircuts that are like you
know life-changing life-changing
are important every now and then but to
keep like your bi-annual
fresh chop trim haircut and being so
pleased with it your fresh layers your
ends are all healthy
nothing feels better than that yeah i
don't need like a
a life-changing haircut just yet i feel
like i've had a lot of change in last
year like bruno
and i've moved and so i'm good on the
change front right now
yeah but eventually i'm going back don't
you feel like it's really starting to
settle in like
how long because we're coming up on the
like almost one year anniversary mark of
when lockdown started like
it's really at least for me starting to
settle in like how long
this has been and how it feels endless
you know i've always felt like
there was some like end in sight to all
this but now i'm just like well it's
been a year and it's like we're in this
weird period i don't know what it's like
in other states i think that some states
like
have bars and restaurants open but like
we are we're completely pretty much on
lockdown
not like as crazy as it was but i'm just
cannot believe it's been almost a year
like
what the [ __ ] yeah 25 just like
shouldn't count for me
no i agree just a year of your life down
the tubes i mean think of kids who are
in school like in the third grade barely
had third grade
you know what they're going from second
to fourth no and like
truly like in 20 years i'm gonna be very
very selective with my doctors
because those kids miss third grade
that's so true it's like i don't let's
say i get arrested i need a lawyer i'm
like well where were you in the third
grade no where were you in
2020 were you in law school in 2020
zooming yeah from your bedroom yeah
it's gonna be a no from me it's gonna be
an absolute november no i'm kidding of
course like lawyers are lawyers
that's like so pragmatic no but um
i just cannot believe it's been a full
calendar well not exactly but it's
coming up on being a full year
yeah one year anniversary
speaking of things coming up we are now
five days away i mean honestly i've been
able to sleep at all
this entire week because i'm just like
thinking about my book and like checking
the the amazon page like just like
looking at it um
if you haven't pre-ordered it yet which
i can't imagine there would be anyone
who hasn't
girl with no job.com book has all the
links i've never been
big for pre-ordering and like for
anything yeah
because one time when i was in high
school i pre-ordered like the hannah
montana album on itunes
and then midnight came and it never
showed up and i had to go and buy it so
i just that was my only experience so i
understand that if there are people who
are like not into pre-ordering well the
thing is like when i was promoting my
comedy special there were very like not
a lot of pre-orders and i was like
freaking out because
i'm like this is my debut and like no
one cares and
people really don't pre-order movies
like at all like
literally i think the amount of people
who ended up purchasing my comedy
special was like
30x the amount of people who actually
pre-ordered it um
but with books because you just like
forget and and they ship it to you like
yeah i think
it's much more common but you're right
not everyone pre-orders but
you still can at girlsnowjob.combook
audio ebook and hardcover versions are
all available and the ebook
and the hardcover version come with
photos like here
so exciting i don't wanna yes the kindle
version does come with photos yes i
actually asked my publisher a few days
ago because um
people were asking me but it's at the
end you know in the hardcover it's in
the middle
kindle the pictures are at the end and
just a reminder if you have a question
for claudia about her book email the
redheadsbookclub
gmail.com and ask away it's going to be
a great episode
and ben i've been like giving him [ __ ]
he hasn't read my book and like am i
right to be like so offended
yeah yeah we really don't ask for much
no especially like both his parents read
it we really don't really
both his parents read it and his
sister's like halfway through and i'm
like this is just
i'm like i'm trying to be offended but
like i'm [ __ ] offended he said i'm
waiting for the audiobook i'm like
you're not gonna listen to eight hours
of an audiobook like just sit down and
read it
especially he got home early from work
yesterday and he had like nothing to do
i'm like just sit your ass down
and [ __ ] read it so he made it
halfway but i'm just like annoyed that i
have to like
badger him into doing it i feel like so
naggy like just do you want to read my
book
yeah that's sad it's really sad speaking
of ben um
he and i are going to do a patreon
episode about our cleanses but i wanted
to talk to you because last week you
said like i was getting ben to do the
cleanse he was never going to do it and
you're going to have all these groceries
yes and it's going well for him oh it's
going well for him but it is not going
well for the kitchen like there's just
spinach all over the floor like
and he does clean up but like it's a lot
of maintenance
no it's not even that it's like ben
means so well like he really does and if
i
if i say to him like the housekeeper was
just here can you please clean up after
yourself after making your smoothie
he will say yes and really mean it and
he will clean to the best of his ability
but the best of his ability is just not
going to cut it in my house and like my
standards
and i'm not even that crazy like i would
only like okay the floor there's a
crumbs everywhere he i know he doesn't
see that but like
wiping down the counter that's like a
basic cleaning thing
he just thinks like putting all the
spinach away and like
moving the blender to the corner like is
cleaning when it's like no no
do the dishes wipe down the counter take
the dust buster and pick up all the
spinach you left on the floor
yeah well does theo get into the spinach
on the floor well ben is now
on the part of the cleanse where he's
add grapes and grapes are i don't know
if you know that's very toxic to dogs
like be really careful
and so i just don't like having grapes
in the house it's like having like a
nuclear weapon in your
closet like i just really don't like it
because you know i know things happen
you drop a grape they're little
i just don't like how i don't want to
set myself up for that so ben is just so
reckless and literally i'm sitting doing
my makeup and he goes hey claud i forget
like
how many grapes does it take for like
you know a dog to die
and i'm like did you give theo a grape
like i literally started freaking out
he was just asking but it's like i don't
like having you know something so
powerful in the hands of someone so
clumsy
yes that's very fair i think so too very
fair
okay well i think we can now get into oh
is it not excerpt have you gotten
feedback on the expert
expert no i haven't so maybe i should do
another one okay
page
page 118.
you got it ma'am 118. here we go
this is the chapter um
what is it on body image of my decision
to you know
uh get plastic surgery go into fat camp
as a kid and just
you know my journey being a famous fat
person because there are not a lot of us
um but we're a powerful unit really
truly powerful
um okay so this is uh oh this is
actually great
talking about how like i wasn't sure
whether i should post on instagram like
about my chin
surgery um like the before and after
pictures that they took at the doctor
and i actually
put the before and after pictures in
this insert with all the photos
that you get on the e-book and the
hardcover so this is just a little bit
about my journey
there um on my final post-op visit to dr
geezy she showed me the official before
and after pictures
i was floored and i obviously couldn't
wait to post them on instagram
i was a little nervous to post not for
fear of judgment or ridicule
but because i hated the way i looked in
the before shot they were so
before but i've always been open and
honest with my audience and my chin was
no exception i didn't sign up for this
life to do it half ass so i posted the
photos with no regrets
and you'll just have to see what happens
next in girlsnowjob.com
no regrets no regrets thank you for
listening to my excerpt and
i promise we're almost at the end of the
road of me talking about this book joe i
just want you guys to like buy it so you
can know what i'm talking about you know
yeah just want everyone to feel included
yeah i think that's really fair
thank you now do you think it's time oh
for sure yeah and i'm totally
because i actually really want to talk
about housewives and in order to do that
we must and i really want to talk about
jojo siwa so we must
deliver the past five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
oh my god [ __ ] do you [ __ ] do you hear
that
no my heart is beating so fast oh my god
take a breath oh god
no
[Laughter]
whoa did i pass out must've been the rda
the show's over let me take some of my
meds oh great let me go home
today's episode is brought to you by
usual wines usual wines are wines for
the modern drinker
each bottle is 6.3 ounces which is a
heavy pour or about a glass and a half
of wine
so you've no more pouring wine down the
sink when you don't want to finish the
bottle
because of the single serve format and
the bottle design usual usual is always
fresh
you have no more flat bubbly or stale
rose the wines are low carb and have
zero grams of grams of sugar
the usual options have a red blend a
rose and a sparkling white wine called
brut
we also have usual spritz a low alcohol
8.5 alcohol beverage low calorie wine
spritzer that's made of sparkling wine
and guava juice like white cloth for
grownups
each serving has just 83 calories wow
that's really good
um first of all usual wines like are
great tasting wines of course but i
think like the genius concept is the
size of the bottle of wine
because i've on more than one occasion
like went to open a second bottle and
then obviously didn't finish the second
bottle it's just such a waste the usual
ones are the perfect amount it's like a
really hefty serving so
two should usually be good um if you
want to check out their website go to
usualwines.com
and use our discount code toast for
eight dollars off your first order
and try your first class on us that's
usual wines u-s-u-a-l-wines.com and the
discount code is toast
for eight dollars off your first order
to try your first glass on
us they're fabulous wines and
fabulous products so make sure for your
next gals night in if you need a good
brute
i that's been probably the best part of
becoming
host of the morning toast is finding out
about usual wines and finally getting my
hands on a good brute
yeah so important so important okay
first story claire crawley
is speaking out about her breakup
she posted to instagram saying i was
made aware of a mutual quote
statement at the same time you all were
so i needed some time to really digest
this basically
dale's both for the both of them and she
did not sign off on that
speaking for my relationship my intent
speaking for myself my intentions with
this relationship have always been very
clear
so the truth is i am crushed this was
not what i expected or hoped for and i'm
still trying to process this
with kovid battling severe anxiety post
show balancing a public new relationship
all while slowly losing my mother
it hasn't been ideal circumstances but
that is life right
i have been looking forward to the light
at the end of the tunnel our
relationship was not perfect but i can
say that i was genuinely invested with
all of my heart
like and to me reading between the lines
means that he was not of course
i may not have all the answers but i do
know this i will continue to show up
stand by my word and be committed to
love well i was actually
really doubting whether or not she would
continue to show up so for i'm really
glad we got that sort of clarity
i actually feel really really bad for
claire i also feel bad for dale i think
in a lot of ways like he just got swept
up into this
like committed relationship that i think
he didn't really want to be a part of as
much as claire did
so of course there's going to be fallout
from that but a
bachelor producer is like really i feel
like co-workers stale into this whole
thing and
i mean yeah bachelor producers coerce
dale into this whole thing
thus leading to claire thinking it was
real so she i do feel bad because she
must be like genuinely crushed
yeah i don't know i think they
definitely encourage him and
but when they when it was the beginning
of the season and it was the two of them
really vibing
so hard yeah um
he was it like that wasn't producers
making no he was flirting
yeah no so they had like a genuine
connection i just think if she had
just had some patience like she
it might have unfolded differently yeah
i do feel really bad for her because
she's gotten a lot of [ __ ] she deals
with a lot of things personally and now
she's single which is like
the antithesis of why she went so now
she has all the grief from the journey
but not even the
you know the one of the positives which
is a partner
yeah i'm looking at her instagram page
and it's just all pictures of her and
dale and it's
just sad i think dale just like wanted
to gtfo
so bad and he just like put up the
statement like he just wanted to like
put this behind him
so it's like i have empathy for both of
them but i really just feel bad for
claire because now
she's been through this whole journey
like she was really made into a joke in
so many ways and
and now she's left
single like which was the whole point of
going right where she started but just
all with all the negative attention
and the anxiety yeah and like uh haters
yeah and she is chaotic and we have to
give her that but i i don't know i feel
bad for her especially because i know
she struggles with a lot personally like
with her mom i think has alzheimer's and
it's just
it's hard and i do feel bad for her i
really do yeah but
what a journey this was an adventure
these two these two
quite the adventure yeah i i hope they
also don't continue to be like messy on
social media like that's
honestly one of my least favorite things
um it is one of my least favorite things
but i do i'm sure we'll get a little
messier than just
right now these two statements and i do
like to get a little taste of what was
actually going on
oh i decided like the mutual love and
respect and we will always be friends
you know where as a relationship i feel
like with bachelor nation that was like
so much more than we saw was so toxic
and we never really got like a full
recap on that cassie and colton yeah
there's like a lot of tears a lot but
there was so much messiness like there
was a restraining order there was a spy
cam
yeah there was a tracker no right so i'm
saying like i want
a colton tell-all book but on that no i
i don't
who wants to hear from colton's point of
view delusional one of them cassie
colton wrote a book he didn't
he chose not to talk about anything
pretended like his relationship was
perfect and a month later they were
broken up
not interested i would actually be
annoyed if i spent money on that book at
least my book is honest
like i literally tell all the truths in
here that's true like
people literally bought your book only
for you to lie straight to their faces
and it's also like
when you wrote the book obviously you
were having relationship troubles right
broke up literally
one month later so maybe wait to write
your memoirs
until this huge life-altering moment
life-altering
thing happens especially when you're
famous for your relationships you know
because you're going on the bachelor
it's not like you're an
athlete you don't need to wait if you're
an athlete you don't need to wait for
you and your wife to get divorced to
write your memoir but yeah when you're
famous for being the bachelor and you're
famous for being in a relationship
it would be you know your relationships
going down the tubes maybe wait till the
thing that's interesting happens i mean
talk about a fall from grace for colton
underwood i mean
from nfl bench warmer when i think about
like
the amount that i stand and like
it's shocking how how quickly and how
drastically your opinion about someone
can change
i mean he totally let us down and when
you think about his career as a whole
not just the bachelor but everything
before that like all right he was like
kind of like a failed nfl player but
then he started dating ali raisman
you're like oh you know what maybe this
is going to be
it for this guy and well it's not like
we had heard about him before
no but i mean like for him he was
probably like all right my life's not
over like i'm dating a [ __ ] gold
medal olympian yeah and then when he
joined the bachelor it was like
obviously a step down but there's so
many perks that come with the bachelor
like fame and money that like you know
what
the stigma is not as bad as it as it is
and now that all this time has passed
and he's literally just like a disgraced
bachelor
stalker like it's really crazy how we
went from like olympic gold medal to
potential jail time like it's crazy
yeah it's crazy but he's been low-key he
uh he like deleted his instagram
did he post sargon yeah last i checked
it's just so weird like he went from
being
the thirstiest person on the planet like
remember him and cassie larry started a
music video for like
a no-name country singer just so they
could be in a music video yeah
well that is you know part of the
playbook it is
but not for two leads like yeah that's
for like uh
like danielle malpe is in a few music
videos like uh
someone is in a darius wrecker one too
like there's a bunch of girls from
bachelor nation but they're not the
winners
yeah but lauren fishnow well that was
her husband
yeah it counts so i think if you're
asked to be a music video you should
always say yes
oh a hundred percent also if you could
have the life
or like yeah if you could have the life
of any post bachelor
alum boy or girl who would you want
i mean it's it's a it's a bad question
because it's like the worst thing you
could do is like covet someone's life
and never who do you think has the best
life
like i mean of course lauren and the
lanes are just everything of the sort
but there's a few people who look like
they're really living their best lives
yeah i mean a lot of them still stay in
the bachelor circle and like make their
living off of like
showing up in the bachelorette podcast
the ropertol bears have such a full and
happy life
that's a really good one the lanes and
the roper tolberts for sure
yeah emily maynard johnson yeah but she
like is not about like i
when i think of her like i know she was
on the bachelor not once but twice
but i literally don't even consider her
a part of bachelor nation because she's
just like
so doing her own thing yeah i love her
love her
okay next story is also a bit of
bachelor news that i found really
surprising
abc executive robert mills addresses
matt james's
lower bachelor ratings he says people
are just getting to know him
so matt james's bachelor premiere had
the lowest ratings in franchise history
but that's shocking that is shocking
that was the first time that i heard
that i had no idea i would have
never guessed me either because people
are at home what else are they doing
and this they made this season look
really good yeah and by the way
if people watched uh claire and tasha
at literal like a motel in palm springs
i don't know why they want to watch matt
james at like a palace in nema colin
right and also i feel like sometimes
when the bachelor bachelorette is chosen
it's a polarizing choice it's like oh
i'm not going to watch next season
because i know that person i don't want
to watch that person
but none of us knew like none of us knew
matt james so it's like who wouldn't
want to watch what grit might you have
with him
and robert mills is saying that like he
thinks people aren't watching yet
because they don't know him so they're
not inclined to watch but i think
the fact that they don't know him should
be a reason why the ratings are even
higher i think his assessment as to why
the ratings aren't high
is completely i mean no one can really
truly know why
no but i mean i guess do they say how
many people below five million
which is that's just crazy that that
many people watch a bachelor like i know
because i know like
bravo um ratings and like atlanta and
beverly hills i think are like some of
the watch most watched shows
and like for really good seasons they
hit like 2.53
yeah but abc is abc yeah i just i would
want to ask like about the person who
typically watches the bachelor why
they're not watching the season if
they're not
okay here that would be a good way to
find out if you guys are listeners of
this podcast and you usually watch the
bachelor or a bachelorette and you're
not watching the season
leave a comment on our instagram and let
us know why like i'm just genuinely
curious maybe
like you just don't know matt so you
just don't care that was the reason why
i
wanted to watch it like i just hate all
the baggage like
oh just show up like everyone has a
stupid thing like
unlovable remember like everyone has
like a catchphrase
it's just so contrived now and it really
is a breath of fresh air even though i
do think matt james is like a little too
nice
for this particular role but you have to
watch the show in order to know that you
know i'm just saying mike my critique no
no yeah
but um if you are someone who usually
watches the franchise but is not
watching
do let us know i'm genuinely curious
the robert mill said i actually think
you're going to see ratings rise more
exponentially than you would during
previous seasons
because people are going to start
talking about it and word of mouth is
going to kick in
well this article is also press for the
bachelor so he's not going to say like
ratings i think are going to continue to
go down yeah but also
as the season picks up the drama starts
really happening these are always the
worst episodes of any season
and so once things start to happen like
i'm sure
with claritasia season when claire left
like more people tuned in
100 when claire blew up the bachelor
yeah so as those
sort of big dramatic moments happen i'm
sure there'll be more viewers but i just
thought that was really interesting and
i don't
i don't think it's a reflection on the
casting choice i think it's more of
people are really tired of the bachelor
and it's just situational too like at
some point i was thinking about this
last night like
enough is enough like with television
like i like to put our foots down
we do and i put my foot down on feet
i have put my foot down a few times with
bachelor nation i didn't watch becca
season
i didn't watch hannah brown's season i
was just like so over it
you get so burnt out so maybe just like
a lot of people got burnt out from like
the past couple seasons where nobody got
engaged that they were like all right i
need a break
yeah also i think that i mean i know
that the bachelor producers don't really
care about this but like with every
breakup and like this now this
clarendale thing like
it makes the franchise so
stupid almost what was the point of all
of that yeah for them to be together for
a month
and i think that with other shows like
are you the one
they don't really brand the shows as
like really you're gonna fall in love
like you expect the people to break up
it's not that crazy
but the bachelor has always taken itself
so seriously and really set itself apart
from those other shows
and for a while they were going really
strong with like a lot of couples
and now they're it's like in the last
five seasons
colton did not end up with someone
claire did not end up with someone
um becky and garrett have broken up
like there's just so many mm-hmm that
it's kind of boring hannah brown didn't
end up with that oh thank you hannah
brown
yeah so just something you should know
no i do i found i find that interesting
because i don't keep up with bachelor
ratings i do with bravo because i find
those really really interesting
um so i i never hear about bachelor
ratings dropping i feel like they're
always consistent so like this is kind
of crazy
yeah the beginning of the end hopefully
okay next up here's why people think
jojo siwa came out as queer
though young jojo siwa has been a gay
icon for a few years her attention for
rainbows bubbly personality perfect
teeth
and knack for going viral has her 16th
that's true by out um magazine it's
hilarious
essentially made her family they say
we're absolutely joking noting
makes nothing makes you lgbtq plus
besides actually being lgbtq
plus but um jojo siwa posted a tick tock
yesterday
in a completely rainbow it was a white
hoodie with like rainbow
it was her i think it was her own merch
but it was rainbow themed merch and she
had those led lights on her wall that
were all lit up in rainbow
and she was lip-syncing to lady gaga's
born this way
she was listening to lady gaga's born
this way the bridge which is like
not only the most iconic part of the
song but i think has is the reason why
born this way has become like
literally like the gay anthem of our
generation i think most queer people
would agree
um and the lyrics to that part of the
matter by
lesbian transgender life you're on the
right track baby you were born to
survive
so i don't know why people are like did
she didn't she she did like
it's so clear and i think this is so
great i think jojo c was like
always been like a wonderful role model
for people and the way she like protects
her brand and it's super
kid safe and i just think like this is
so cool
and so wonderful and i'm so proud of her
and jojo siwa like
you know what treat yourself tonight
have a pack of marlboro reds on me
yeah by the way that was a joke there's
a rumor that joe josie was a chainsmoker
not
a rumor it's like i read it somewhere
once and i just like completely believed
it it's
so funny it's so funny she might not be
so i just want to put it out there but
if you want to celebrate tonight jojo
you have my permission to smoke a pack
the reds are on us the reds are honest
you know this is awesome but
a lot of the headlines the people are
it's not confirmed you know because you
have a caption
there's a lot that she's alluding to but
she hasn't officially come out but
we are taking this as that she's coming
yeah cause then there was another tick
tock that she made with a bunch of other
creators
who i believe are all queer as well and
the caption was like now you're one of
us jojo or whatever so like
it's it's pretty overt but i just don't
think anyone wants to make a full
assumption until like we hear it
in perfectly clear words from jojo but
yes
regardless i think that this is
wonderful and i just think it's
it's like the same thing i'm saying with
high school musical the musical this
year it's like it's just such a great
time to be a kid
yes well aside from not going to school
party oh no sorry it's a terrible time
aside from missing the third grade
terrible time but you know what i mean
yeah okay next story kylie jenner's
striking back at critics
um because the internet was in an uproar
over her shower
yes so the other day kylie posted a
video of her shower
and um it was like pink and black super
cool marble
and she got roasted because the water
pressure like looks pretty weak it's
just
not what you would expect like a 100
million dollar home it's really was
giving me like
camp shower pressure right so kylie took
back to instagram to clear a few things
up one that was the shower in her office
yes if you've watched her office tour on
youtube which if you haven't just
go check it out it's so fabulous she's
like a suite like for
she's a wardrobe room for a glam room
and then she does a lot of photo shoots
so she has a sickening master bathroom
there
and so i guess the water pressure there
is like not necessary
but i have a theory now that i'm
thinking about it and then she showed us
her shower at home that is like
state-of-the-art
automatic you do the temperature it
looks like a hot tub i never saw a
shower without a nozzle like it just was
a button
yeah crazy right i'm glad that she just
showed us all the shower features that
we are missing in our lives like that's
i think what we all expected
but i feel like this water pressure in
her
office shower like might intentionally
not be that great because i feel like
she never
would wash her hair there it would just
be like a rinse you know because she's
always glammed up
yeah so you ever try and not wash your
hair in a shower that's having like
crazy pressure from the top it's
impossible oh you know what that's so
interesting
i never thought to change the pressure
in my shower when i'm not washing my
hair
i don't change the pressure but if i was
building a shower in my office
knowing that i probably not gonna like
you know come out
with wet hair and no makeup i don't know
if this was intentional i think you're
looking too much into it but i just
think she doesn't need
such strong pressure for her office
because she's probably just taking like
body showers
well i was thinking that like maybe just
the nozzle wasn't turned all the way up
and like she just wanted the video and
she did not think people would be like
getting so pressed on the internet about
the pressure of the shower
i just think maybe the both you know you
sometimes you gotta turn two nozzles
maybe one was only turned halfway
i mean i just it is odd when i saw the
video on her instagram i had the same
thought i was like that's pretty weak
yeah no and water pressure is like a
coveted thing like and
if you're a billionaire like kylie is
like you have pressure out the ass so i
just think
like maybe one of the buttons wasn't on
or something i don't know
i think i think it never bothered her
because she's never looking for that you
know
deep clean shower while she's at work
that's fair like
i agree i don't think she's washing her
hair putting it in the towel and then
going home like
she's yeah and like shaving her legs and
exfoliating and all of that
i mean honestly i miss so much of
kylie's youtube content i feel like we
talk about her youtube content like
every quarter because that's when she
puts out a video um and recently she's
like putting out videos that are just
her instagram stories like combined and
to me that's offensive
yeah i haven't even checked them out
like that's rude but her and kendall
took this trip oh my god to mexico
i know it's the most sickening house
i've ever saw except kylie rocking that
mole woman hair
i just i hate that look kim used to do
it all the time too like hair literally
down to your ankles
kylie's was way longer than kim's was
but i hate
that look yeah despise yeah sorry no i
i think that's fair this is also in the
week of me like offending haircuts like
i've been just like talking [ __ ] about
haircuts but you know what have whatever
haircut you want
you have strong opinions i have strong
opinions but like do do you
um fifth and final story a little biz
news a little
biz news i feel like people might have
seen this because
netflix is soaring oh really yeah
neptune [ __ ] about some stock
netflix shares exploded 18 in wednesday
trading pushing the stock to a record
high
despite the earnings shortfall on
tuesday evening the
um that was just like the next sentence
is a lot of really like financial
targeting yeah
um but the company surpassed the part
that we care about the company surpassed
200 million paid subscribers
for the first time now why would i need
200 million paid subscribers desperately
yes powered by a world continuing
to consume large amounts of content at
home during the coven 19 pandemic
i find this really interesting because i
feel like for a long time it was known
that
netflix was in debt buying all of this
these movies and
this content and producing it themselves
like really big budget projects and this
is the first time
that they are not so their bet
has paid off oh 100 and i think they
always thought that it would but people
eventually were like
i don't know we're doubtful but i also
think that also
the people who were doubtful could have
never foreseen a pandemic
right all of those factors have
contributed to
netflix story yeah but it also it's
super interesting that netflix is
soaring given the amount of really
premium services out there now that
compete directly with netflix hbo max
disney plus hulu like and the new ones
we've discovery plus the ones we've
gotten in quarantine with the exception
of quibby
um are really stellar yeah like i'm
loving hbo max and loving disney plus
i'm loving one of my
peacock right now and you love discovery
plus and yes i
i like them all i really do we do i
think that they're like a very hulu
you know they're about to have
kardashians so they fixed it hulu has
the best database of
like if you're looking for an old show
desperate housewives lost like it's on
hulu
ugly betty um but the interface we talk
about this once a week here and i just
need someone who works for hulu to like
help me like the interface is so not
premium like whatsoever
i feel like they'll they'll work on a
rebrand soon especially with the
kardashians like they're obviously
investing in themselves
i did think it was kind of crazy that
they chose hulu i'm sure they just went
to like whoever had the most money but
like
hulu in terms of branding is like not
the coolest place on earth
no i'm sure it was just about money and
hulu like really needs the kardashians
and i totally respect my like people who
make choices for money
and because to them it's all the same um
right where and wherever they go
their fans will follow no and it's like
oh the kardashians here are here it's
cool they don't have to worry about
going to the existing cool one
imagine just being like that cool camera
light um
let's dive into the tv recap which is
brought to you by better help
is there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals
uh yeah my crippling anxiety betterhelp
will assess your needs and match you
with your own licensed professional
therapist
where you can start communicating in
under 48 hours it's not a crisis line it
is
not self-help it is professional
counseling done
securely online there's a broad range of
expertise available which may not be
locally available in many areas
this service is available for clients
worldwide where you can log into your
account anytime and send a message to
your counselor
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions
sessions so you won't ever have to sit
in an uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy
betterhelp is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free
to change counselors if needed it's more
affordable than traditional offline
counseling and financial aid is
available
betterhelp wants you to start living a
happier life today
visit their website betterhelp.com toast
that's betterhelp.com
toast and join the over a million people
who have taken charge of their mental
health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using better help that they are
recruiting additional counselors in all
50 states
so the special offer for the morning
toast listeners to get 10 off your first
month
is slash betterhelp.com
check it out and start taking care of
your mental health love it okay where do
you want to go
first oh see because it was on first and
i feel like there's just less to say
um i thought it was good i thought i was
decent i was paying attention the whole
time
i there's so much to talk about there's
so many cuz the season was so
abbreviated and confusing like there was
a lot to
unpack and like blanks to fill in yes
um i thought though like collectively
they didn't look great
um the lighting was harsh for a lot of
them
and the chairs were like small there was
no decor like between them
yeah i didn't think overall that they
look bad i thought emily looked
fantastic i thought gina looked great
i think tina looked the best brown win
bronwyn looked
she was wearing flats like bronwyn no
she wasn't she was wearing those boots
like they were
flat oh it looked like they had a big
heel but they might have had a platform
but like they were flat oh that's not
how i saw it which is just crazy i think
that she looked like
great her hair and makeup looks great
yeah um i thought kelly looked great i
thought elizabeth vargas looked great
and i just thought that shannon's
um foundation was off i thought
shannon's whole look was weird her shoes
were so bizarre
i loved shannon's um concept concept i
love the headband and the go-go dress
and the
platform shoes it's just it's a standing
outfit not a sitting outfit that's
really true um and i loved her hair i
loved what she was going for but it just
it was hard tough on a reunion
the whole reunion was bizarre everyone
was like there's just like no clear
alliances i think for the most part like
it's
everyone against bronwyn but then it's
also like everyone against themselves
and like there's so much infighting
and i just like really i've come to the
conclusion that i tried to give her the
benefit of the doubt
i just don't like bronwyn but i do think
some of the things they say to her are
just [ __ ] evil like
her sobriety is not fake like i don't
think that maybe she's like desperate to
be famous and
purposely got sober for a storyline fine
that doesn't mean she's still a fake
kelly said you think she's a fake
alcoholic and she doesn't believe she
never saw her on cover she never thinks
she had a problem and that like
she's not even a person who needed to
get sober if i had heard this at the
beginning of the season i would have
been wildly offended but now
hearing a lot of the things that we have
heard and knowing that bronwyn has lied
about a lot of
different facets of her life namely that
her and sean have that love condo like
that was all a lie
it's clear that she does things for
story lines and i think the idea
that she got sober i don't think
anyone's questioning the fact that she
is sober and that she's going through
all the steps but that she did that
for the show especially considering day
one was like day one of filming like
it does make you wonder like i so emily
and gina said that they think that like
your sobriety is real but like your
timing and like your motives are
self-serving right and kelly straight up
was like i don't believe you're you to
be an alcoholic and i don't think you
have a drinking problem right but she's
not saying that her surprise that she's
not now sober
no no no she's saying the same thing as
emily and gina just she
is sort of like no no emily and gina
said they they thought she had a
drinking problem
but they're just like skeptical of her
timing whereas
kelly was like you never had a drinking
problem you made up the problem when
andy asked who here thinks that bronwyn
had a drinking problem before she got
sober
gina was like i never thought that but
but gina's not doubting the fact that
now knowing what she knows that bronwyn
like did the right thing
and needed to get help she went to a
meeting with you oh right because they
had gotten to meetings with her so they
saw a different side so maybe that's
what kelly needs to do
yeah i just think like kelly took that
one like a little too far i think kelly
just
i think there's a lot more that to come
with bronwyn
yeah that given a lot of other things
that are going to come up
some women have every reason to question
every single thing that she says well
the cocaine
thing that's coming up now is so crazy
and i do think it will result in bronwyn
being let go from the show i mean
we how could it not how could it not we
have like this has happened a few times
where it's like someone
and housewives are always saying and
doing crazy things but every now and
then someone like really crosses this
invisible line
leanne lockin with harry bringing him
and like everyone collectively was like
yeah she's gotta go
and i think that it's gonna be this but
i also think i was looking at these
women and i'm like
you know what i think you all have to go
like the show it's just
it needs to start from scratch and i
think they keep trying to remove
elements and like build around but i
don't think it's it because
honestly the only woman i know i'm like
obsessed with her but i think
the only woman who really can and should
stay maybe elizabeth vargas too but
emily simpson like she is a real
housewife like she lives a fabulous life
she has a nice home and she her husband
like make a nice living
and she also is now like getting
involved in drama like she has both
elements whereas like
some of the women have neither and i
don't know it's just it's like it's a
broken franchise i think that bronwyn
and shannon need to go
100 i think that emily's great i think
that gina contributes a lot to the show
and and
she's right some of the time and i think
that i think she's a good housewife
i think she is too i just like i think
just don't like her kelly is a good
housewife and i think that elizabeth
is well on her way well also i think
elizabeth's divorce settlement
what i'm gathering from the reunion
dynamics is that
those four women get along with one
another yeah i think emily and gina
obviously we know that they're close i
think emily and kelly are very close me
too
and i think that the three of them have
no problem with elizabeth no and now
that elizabeth um
got her divorce settlement and i have a
feeling it was like 500 million dollars
like i feel i don't know why it was
getting the vibe that it was like a lot
of money
that i'm ready for elizabeth vargas like
should have waited till her divorce was
done before she could
join the show just be so she could a
talk about it and be just like
be rid of that like be more free yeah so
i'm actually looking forward but she was
like
she was trying a little too hard to
reunion elizabeth so like have like a
like a punchy moment
oh you thought so i felt that way about
bronwyn oh that's bronwyn though to a
tea like did you see those paparazzi
pictures
me and heather mcdonald were talking
about it on our podcast we were dying do
you see like paparazzi
caught bronwyn and sean going into a sex
shop where bronwyn just happened to be
wearing a necklace that said
gay okay i can't it's just like what are
the odds you know
what are the odds they're just she's so
thirsty and her motives are so
clear i agree we gotta definitely get
rid of bronwyn and shannon
even though i really like shannon for a
while but she said just she's just
two of the old school oc
tres amigos yeah trace and miguel's like
googling each other like it's just a new
world
i agree and she it's just i think
her time has has come and gone yeah
and also like just if i have to hear
about coven more on my reality tv like
i'm literally just gonna throw my tv out
out the window because like i'm living
it okay like please leave me alone like
it's so
torturous yeah yeah um salt lake city
was
so good and i have this theory and i
need you to hear me out are you done
talking about osa
um okay let me talk to you about salt
lake city because
i was getting so frustrated this episode
of course like gen shaw queen of like
accepting apologies and pretending like
they never happened
and that was crazy but i really was
getting annoyed with lisa barlow like i
think
she might be one of my least favorite
housewives of all time and i have a
theory mm-hmm
um so you were the one who actually told
me like when you saw her on watchdog
live for the first time you were like it
was so clear that like she's just been
dying to be a housewife
so i think off in salt lake city lisa
barlow's probably like the most
cool one of this group i think like when
she got cast it was like good for the
show i think she's like a girl about
town a social light very well connected
and she's probably quote unquote cooler
in salt lake city than any of the other
women
that means nothing to us because we
don't live in salt lake city and i just
like who i like from the show
right and so i think that she was kind
of being like uh
like keeping everyone at you know in
arm's length like trying to be like the
cool girl
trying to have that you come to me
thinking that would transfer to the
screen
we don't know what the sundance film
festival social
climb ladder is like like i i'm getting
the vibe though that like she thought
that like that would all translate
and now i think people's favorites are
pretty much like heather
and whitney i think that's where the
audience is lying
nobody cares that lisa's like a cool
girl in real life because on camera
you're a mean girl
and you're not contributing anything to
the show anything like you're not
friends with any of these women
you're honestly bringing meredith down
and i think at the reunion we're gonna
see like a huge change because all lisa
wants is to be like a beloved housewife
and she thought she could do that by
being herself yeah and that's not
working yeah she needs to be with the
with the people who are now the cool
girls
which is like heather and whitney and i
think we're gonna see like uh
a huge shift from i think she thought
she was going to end up being like the
coolest cat in town she thought she was
doing something she
and she was doing nothing of the store
yeah she was actually doing absolutely
nothing
yeah like her like going to vegas and
not telling anyone like logistically
that just doesn't work for me like do we
need to get you a room
like it was just she was annoying me on
so many levels she's taking this so
personally and taking it way too far
and i will say though in her defense
even though i'm so here for whitney
what whitney did at the party repeating
a rumor that she heard from mary
unverified and going to jen with it
about meredith and lisa like they have
every right to be pissed at her and up
until the race car thing
she hadn't apologized once she
apologized it seems like they're ready
to move on and i just want to make sure
that they do move on
yes but i can understand
that they were like what are you doing
yes but i do wish they would recognize a
little bit more that not only okay yeah
she said the thing that mary said and
that was bad but she was also looking
out for meredith because
no one is even talking about how jen
shot not once but twice has been
so disrespectful and nasty to meredith
about her marriage telling everyone they
were separated before meredith had a
chance
and now starting rumors that she was
seen with some guy and so whitney in her
own weird way in her drunk way
was trying to help meredith as well and
no one's talking about that yeah no
meredith is and i think meredith sees
that that's why meredith was on the
plane
and is was quicker to forgive whitney
but lisa
has her own experience with whitney they
were already on a weird foot then
whitney does that whitney needed to
apologize
and if lisa can act she said she
accepted it if she can actually move on
sorry i'm cool with it yeah but she
needed to apologize she waited a little
bit of a long time i mean that [ __ ] i
wouldn't get on a plane with
like that but if you're on a housewives
show like in real life yeah yeah but
like that car ride to
the it was so awkward i'm sorry
the motor the the car racing thing where
lisa was being like such a big talker
and it was literally driving so slow
like that for me
was the highlight of the episode also
the highlight of the episode was heather
gaye's
double date with uh sharif and and when
she said he's tall he's dark he's
handsome he's alive he'll like he'll
work
i was dying and then the guy was like
boring and sober and she was like
thanks jen for bringing me to this sober
ted talk she was being
so funny she is a queen like she is the
the star yes
i want to talk about what jen did for
her with the shopping day which was so
cute and sweet and i and it was like the
second attempt on jem's behalf to like
do something nice for heather okay and i
say one thing
what i didn't think it was so nice and
so sweet well like there's an itinerary
like it's actually rude to
to whitney yeah like you just work on
your own schedule like whitney
coordinated this trip
i i completely agree and now watching
that watch what happens live we know
that heather actually did want to go
race car driving
but the idea that jen took time to plan
something to call people to do something
special for heather
i think is a really nice generous thing
for a person to do
however the fact that after they
finished their shopping
whitney fell off the bar oh my god oh my
god oh my god
i was like in my ankle hurt me too i
thought she was literally going to like
like fall on her it was crazy but she
was fine it was crazy but she was fine
sorry continue no but so they finished
the shopping and so jen brings up
whitney and just goes off on heather for
supporting whitney and it's like
made me feel like jen had been doing
these nice things to like
in to get heather's on her side to go
against whitney and like
i am now just skeptical so skeptical
also people are forgetting not only are
whitney and had their friends
they are cousins like family is family
of course you're always a man i would
get
as a kid if i didn't take my cousin's
side like i literally get smacked like
you
take your cousin's side of course even
if you think and i don't even think
whitney's really that wrong
yeah but like of course she's taking and
so for jen to not only
pretend like the apology never happened
but then demand that heather take her
aside
is so delusional yeah she is really
starting to piss me off and she's
getting
she's an anger problem she was getting
so heated and it was literally just two
people sitting and talking like
chill yeah a pet peeve of mine that i'm
realizing is when someone
accepts an apology and then does not
move on or
just pretend like that apology didn't
happen it happened with mary two times
and it's it's really frustrating as a
viewer also mary like still sitting in
her closet still not leaving her house
like she's literally on coronavirus
lying down
um i understand of course why she didn't
go to the trip like
this is where like housewives gets weird
where it's like yes honestly mary's
right
but jen is with the group so like yeah
one of you gotta go
yeah yeah i mean it's hard to go on a
trip i feel like mary is just like
writing herself out of the show
you know she she gives no [ __ ] whereas
like lisa barlow i feel like
is like this is her dream come true on
watch rap and live last night
um they opened the vault and heather had
posted on her instagram in 2014 a
picture of andy cohen was like
i love this guy and they were like dying
and heather was like no honestly like
manifest your dreams people on instagram
and it's what's so funny is like
i thought her response was so great and
she just owned it whereas like if that
had been lisa like it just would have
been
something so it wasn't cringy like the
fact that she wasn't
obviously but that's like remember when
jackie goldschneider that picture of her
at theresa's
that's and she tried to like play it off
but she honestly didn't do a good job
like i thought the way heather just
embraced it she's like yeah like i
[ __ ] love andy like
yeah i thought it was so cool because it
was like a like
a cast member that you're now beefing
with no it's it's crazy that
that was crazy i like selectively forgot
about that i'll never forget
never she went to teresa's book signing
with her kids and took a picture and
like of course the photo
resurfaced the season that she joined
and it was just the season that she
joined in cape but i'm surprised there's
not more
i mean like every middle-aged woman in
america
watches housewives and some of them
become housewives yeah
i'm actually surprised it doesn't happen
more but i i thought heather handled it
well
meredith i wanted to say one more thing
about oh my god the scene with her
grocery shopping for brooks like
i know mary's writing herself out of the
show but i wish brooks would
like gluten-free dairy phrase toy
framing and are these
dog traits that he's doing something and
i think he's gonna
i think he's seen by now that he's not i
mean i i
know he's wishing he could go back and
edit all these episodes himself out he'd
rather not be in it at all he's coming
off
so bratty he's so bratty and not funny
yeah
oh he started so strong he started so
strong
okay um anything else about the episode
you want to talk about no just
still a great show really enjoying it
last night was a good night of
of housewives for me yeah meredith and
heather ron watch robin's live and
honestly there was like an awkward vibe
i feel like they are not friends
but i also think it's hard to vibe with
someone on zoom yeah but
do you see that they had carl from
summer house like come and be a mystery
man set up with heather
that was weird i was so weirded out me
too
i was really trying to think who it was
i couldn't think of two people
i'm seeing maybe someone from vanderpump
rules yeah because there aren't that
many like
um single men single men on bravo that
are like above
35 yeah um and if they are they're
married to a housewife oh of course
and so i was just like what in the what
that was weird what yeah and the last
time she was on they set her up with
someone from below deck and she said
they've been texting
that's really cute i just love heather i
love her openness to people i know and
just like being the ultimate single girl
everyone wants to set you up with
and she's just has such an open mind and
i think she's having the time of her
life being
a housewife and i'm just i'm like so
happy for her yeah and i think that
something that we've seen her struggle
with is like her wanting to explore
life outside of salt lake city and the
mormon church community
and i think housewives is the perfect
vessel for her to do that and i
i just wish she wasn't airing during
kobe because she'd be in new york she'd
be in l.a yeah
everywhere living her best life living
her best life she's also friends with
bronwyn
that's unfortunate yeah um all right
tomorrow
we will be recapping southern charm and
i think that is
it for tomorrow night right yep that's
all she wrote make sure to join us
tomorrow for our final show of the week
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast where we live
where we deliver the past five stories
that you need to know every monday
through friday on youtube so if you're
watching us on youtube please feel free
to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
heart rated cast box all the places
forever listen to podcasts
find us the more you chose to leave a
five star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are
my book comes out this tuesday it is
available for pre-order at
girlwithnowjob.com
book the book is called growth on a job
and you can get it anywhere you get
books thank you so much for the support
have an amazing day we'll see you
tomorrow for friday
friday gotta get down on friday